you have two movies coming out that star
bruce willis so uh how did that happen
yeah sometimes when people kind of ask
me like oh you just did you know two
movies
with bruce willis you know starring
they think it just happened overnight or
was one of those things that like you
know that
just kind of hit but you know as a
filmmaker i've been grinding
and doing it for more than a decade
right i mean i
went to film school a while ago and you
know i've been telling stories writing
scripts
making movies so to some people it feels
almost like this overnight thing but no
i've been
i've been at this for a while and it's
taken a while to get to that point where
my work is established enough where
people will come to me and be like oh we
want you to direct this
film or you know we've seen your work
and we feel like your style your vision
would really fit into
the content that we're creating and
that's how those films came about is
you know i did several independent films
that got a lot of buzz a lot of
attention
and they attracted producers who were
like oh hey we're doing these other
movies
are you interested we'd love to hear
your take on them
and it's a process it's like a job
interview right like you go in there and
you read the script
and you come up with your vision for how
you think that film
should be directed can we hear more
about this pitch
yeah when you're as a director when
you're going to direct a script from
another writer or like a studio project
or production company has
you have a certain freedom
to kind of read the script and come up
with your
vision for it and that includes
everything from a lookbook
to cast to how you think the world
is designed and looked and does and and
the visuals and everything just every
little detail
that you can go in there with describing
how you think that film should be made
and it's everything from
you know we're going to use a lot of
steadicam we're going to use handheld
we're going to use these kind of lenses
we're going to develop this sort of arc
with the characters
and and it's going in there with a
confident
vision of how you think that film should
be translated from the script
to the screen and that's really what uh
you know what you're doing as a director
when you read someone else's script
you're taking that and you're sort of
deciphering
how you think uh the best version of
that film
should be made how was it to have this
production company that was it that
worked with bruce or that knew
that had there was another company that
knew the company that worked
yeah approach you and
did you feel like you were validated
like okay now this is like a real
filmmaking thing
[Music]
yeah i mean i definitely feel like it
was uh it was
you know being able to get an approach
to direct a script from another writer
that has you know a-list talent like
bruce willis attached is definitely sort
of a oh
whoa this is finally you know a little
validation of my work
as a filmmaker that people are trusting
me with
telling this story so it was definitely
you know
it elevated the level of okay
the stakes are really high on this one i
really have to step it up and make sure
that
you know i really kind of bring in 100
of my passion and all the knowledge and
experience that i've learned as a
filmmaker an independent filmmaker for
the last decade
about okay how do you tell an
interesting story how do you
you know incorporate elements of indie
filmmaking which is
kind of like that fast-paced quick
uh shooting style into a project where
you have a little bit more money to play
with
but knowing that okay that doesn't mean
that you know you can get wild with it
right i mean there's still those
parameter
parameters of it's got to come in under
schedule under budget
and you want to be able to deliver the
film so that
people are always asking you for the
next one
sorry did they sign on for both movies
or was it
one no you do one and then once you and
that's part of the experience right it's
like
and that's one of the things that that's
one of the lessons that you learn as a
filmmaker
throughout your career is and i've said
it time and time again is work
leads to more work so you do a project
you write a script for someone and then
they're like oh hey we're looking for a
director to direct this
other project that we have we really
liked your
script matt and that other film that you
did would you like to read this script
and give us your take on the project
so that's one of those things that both
as a
filmmaker and everyone in the industry
when you work with a dp
he'll make a film he might meet with a
producer who will hire him on a film
that he ends up directing
or you know you work with an actor and
the film might turn out to be really bad
but
that actor was really incredible in the
film right so you end up hiring him
again on a different film or
that's that's really what that's so much
of this industry and so much of
my career as a filmmaker has been just
one project leading to the next
in terms of the relationships within
that project
and the people you meet and the friends
you make and the collaborations that
happen
leading to the next thing what was the
emotion like
when you found out you got the was it
the first one
yeah it was definitely the emotion that
i felt as soon as i realized
i was going to be directing you know
this film with bruce willis was
a lot of excitement i was just kind of
like whoa i better i better step it up
you know what i mean like i can't i
can't screw this up you know i gotta do
the best i can so
it was sort of like that nerve
nervousness mixed with
uh you know motivation drive more
dedication
like okay you know i gotta step it up
and do do what i can
to to tell the best story possible and
direct the best film possible
within the constraints that i've been
given and
i follow sort of like for me
i've learned to have more of a stoic
reaction in my career to things and i
think that
is what enabled me to have a sustained
sort of career is when bad things happen
you have to be able to kind of look at
it from a stoic mentality of okay
that sucks but we're going to keep going
and then when
something really amazing happens like
you're going to get to do or you've got
this cool thing or whatever
great i love that you know that's good
let's keep going let's keep moving
so it's having that balance where you
can kind of
not let it take you either one direction
or another
is one of those things that i learned
earlier on just reading about like stoic
philosophy and how stoicism helps
helps people in their careers and it's
something that goes back you know
to ancient ancient rome and it's just
something that i've learned and even on
set as a director i try to have that
sort of
stoic mentality on set because if you
have that confidence
and that so don't let the little things
that are going on on set
sort of drive you crazy because they
will you know i mean if you let
either the highs or the lows hit you
then
you'll lose that sort of control and you
want to be able to just go into it
confident almost like a chess match just
going there with confidence
knowing that as things hit you you can
just
keep going take the hit or then you know
something great happens and like okay
this is great enjoy that little second
of it
and then just keep going don't let that
thing kind of don't ride that high to
the point where
it you know you forget what's what's in
the present what's in the moment what's
happening now
so that's really been my best bit of
advice is to
kind of like internalize that stoic
philosophy in your career
you